si cette finale gagne Maxim est champion
du monde si cette finale gagne maxime
est champion du monde le roi qui va
monter il va peut-être faire un coup de
H4 non roi F3 H4 je pense ouai ça ça
gagne c'est sûr H4 le roi monte Maxime
qui va gagner na le sa roiiss la tour
qui va partir de l'autre côté il part en
H7 et les pions qui vont être ramassés
par Maxime pion prend H4 il reprend roi
D5 il va falloir réussir à monter le roi
il va faire un coup de tempo roi E3 son
adversaire va sûrement bouger la tour
mais Maxime c'est sûr qu'il est gagnant
il faut être précis maintenant il faut
être précis oh c'est pas si facile il
peut ramener la tour de l'autre côté
Maxime quiiste tour prend H5 Doua fait
un mouvement là il abandonne maxime est
champion du monde d'échec maxime est
champion du monde d'échec les amis si je
me trompe pas si les règles sont
parfaites c'est fait Maxime l'emporte
les amis